i don't know what just happened you're
in an
office no way do you remember
us no who's you
six am crazy day today um you're coming
with me national television shortly
chuck schumer
blue shot getting my eye objected a
laser on my face
first things first i got to walk the
bear yeah where are you while we're
walking the bears i want to
obviously as i'm trying to tell you a
story bears just like just to do a
little rundown of what's going to happen
today first we're going to head over to
dr bonasali's office
who's my rockstar dermatologist friend
we met not too long ago
probably a year ago at a medical media
event he's letting me use his office
to actually give chuck schumer his flu
shot you don't know
chuck schumer is the senate minority
leader
he's also a good friend of mine we work
together on getting epipens on planes
after my little fiasco over the atlantic
ocean he wants to get his flu shot and i
love when politicians
put their money where their mouth is
where their mouths are where their
mouths are
dr bonicelli how are you let's do the
pounding
yes i know long time elbows because you
can't touch exactly and the cdc just
updated guidelines for aerosolized
particles all that good stuff
i am getting this flu shot because it's
so important for everyone to get it now
more than ever with cold it out there
it's not just your ordinary flu shot
it's the same shot that we've had for
years
but with cobin out there it's really
important to get it so i'm getting it
bright and early
right monday really do you have any
allergies no
no allergies no egg allergies i like the
pink shirt yes
solid color all right so this is going
to be pain free here
go ahead no problem that's it it's easy
it's simple everyone it doesn't hurt and
dr mike will do it for you dr mike will
do it for everyone we can have lines
around his office
but as there are anyway but um
it protects other people too it protects
your family it protects your neighbors
it protects your community so
get it done and hospitals are going to
be so taking a hard hit with covet so
many people are going to be getting sick
we can't have flu people coming in as
well we need to keep everyone healthy so
thank you for leading by example oh no
now we'll do the elbow i think it wasn't
covered i'd give you a book okay save
you schumer
brought donuts like what kind of senator
brings donuts to a doctor's office we're
supposed to be healthy
duncan which one do i want jelly but i
have to lower the mask so i'm not gonna
do it also i gotta get them
a little longer than a few minutes later
i just did
tv talking about coronavirus and how
it's aerosolized and it could live in
the air
maria we in the scientific community
have known this for quite some time
it's nice to see the cdc add this to its
formal guidelines now we're about to
have a consultation with dr monisali
come in here dr monica he runs
the best the biggest dermatology
practice
in new york city i appreciate that and
he doesn't do
just cosmetics folks he actually helps
people who are in need
tell us about the few cases that you've
done recently you had someone who got
knife attacked you helped them with
their scar someone who had a dog attack
actually the really popular
thing that was in the news with the
young boy saving his sister's life
you helped them out pro bono i know you
don't like taking credit for but i'm
forcing you to do it right now
tell us why you did it i mean look we're
doctors we're
supposed to help people right that's our
duty it's our purpose cosmetics is fun
we do a lot of it but
you have to remember why you go to work
every day right and we had a
super sweet girl who was just going to
work um like everybody else she was
attacked and slashed across the face
um it was close to my old office we
helped all right and you couldn't find
this car now if you tried and
bridger walker was the more recent one
um his story went
very global yeah he's a little boy that
stepped in front of a dog so his sister
wouldn't
um wouldn't be attacked he was six years
old and when they interviewed him they
were like you know why'd you do it and
he said
if somebody should die it should be me
it's like a six-year-old right so you
have to help somebody i want to be that
brave
it's one of those things i mean again
purpose is really important so we're
lucky and we're blessed to have
tools and equipment to help those kind
of people and we do our best to do so
for sure all right so what are we doing
today talk to me so for the audience
doesn't know check this out
i have a stye in my eye that's right i
ride
this thing has not gone away in six
months press on it feel it there's a big
ball in there
i've tried massaging it i've tried
compresses i tried everything a little
baby injection
oh we're doing a baby injections to the
eye i'm scared should i be scared it's
funny we got chuck schumer his flu
vaccine and now i'm about to get a
little steroid in the eye
can i go blind um i mean it's possible
okay but can we not is it gonna hurt
talk about it later
[Music]
[Music]
good yeah oh my god i thought i would be
going to a dermatologist's office to get
botox not to get my eye injected for a
spy
give it a couple years tell the audience
what's the purpose of getting the
steroid injection
so essentially what happens there's an
inflamed follicle in there yep um
hair follicle right exactly and we tried
the warm compresses all the other good
stuff
sometimes you have to just drop a little
bit of steroid a little bit just to calm
the inflammation down
it'll reduce the swelling which
definitely is occurring so and
some days i wake up and it's more
swollen than others exactly and a little
bit of pain probably too yeah
so this will kind of calm everything
down let your body kind of go back to
equilibrium these are super common
um around the eye not as much but we do
see them quite a bit and so it usually
takes one or two injections to really
get it to go all right we're moving
we're moving and grooving so what do we
do so because of all this stuff with
social distancing everything you want to
minimize amount of people having to
interact with staff and all that stuff
yep so i would just press
room six and then my guy would go show
you to the to the room
no way all right let's follow him what's
his name we call him timmy
timmy timmy don't get nervous buddy
let's go does he likes talk
is this the room timmy
oh arrived at room six thank you timmy i
appreciate it i'm ready for my close-up
you see the little vein here
he's gonna make it disappear
i love that senator schumer's vaccine
has turned into a spa day this is
anytime you need a prostate exam come on
over am i putting these on yeah
men in black stuff are they upside down
i have a big head no i was gonna say
it's the opposite i have a little head
this is like men in black are you gonna
erase my memory four
three two
i don't know what just happened you're
in an
office no way do you remember us no
who's you
is it gone i can see clearly now
the telling dictator is gone do you see
it's missing so we just used a 532 laser
essentially when you have lasers they
can target different things
so if it's like hair you'll target
pigment um
with something like this it actually
targets heme or the redness that you see
so
if you have rosacea we can do a full
global treatment to reduce the redness
the little capillaries like mike had we
just
the laser kind of goes micro into this
vessel
and then the vessel there's a quote that
i'm gonna massacre but it's if
technology
is good there is no difference between
that and magic
and you just said poof and it went away
all right successfully injected the
schumer sam you ready yeah we did it
baby dan you're right zuma's a good man
schumer is a good man and now he's
protected against the flu
and thereby he's protecting everyone at
home as well now we're heading back to
the studio crossing the street we're
safe
and we're gonna record another video
right now three hours later
all right we had a lunch break had some
pizza because it is technically a cheat
day for us
the lights are lit and i'm about to
record a really fun video
taking a test but i won't tell you what
kind also i have a revelation to make
october is going to be collab month and
we've already recorded some of these
epic
collabs with some of the most popular
youtubers some that you've requested
some that you're not even ready for
it's gonna be epic epic epic so i just
wanted to share my day with you today
it's a crazy day i think it's the
craziest one hour i've had in a really
long time
national tv flu shot to a senator eye
injection my eye's still healing look at
it
look at it now we're filming some more
videos back in the hospital tomorrow
in fact if you want to see a day in my
life that i shot in the hospital
click here i'm going to be recording a
new one of those soon or if you want a
really good laugh
check out this tick tock video that just
dropped last week as always stay happy
and healthy